You know, this is Dr. Connors and in this presentation, we're going to talk about
hormone imbalances and some simple things that you could do from an herbal standpoint.
Well, most of this is herbal that we're going to talk about to deal with some of these.
I know, hormone imbalances can be a huge issue in people's life, can make you feel miserable,
whether you're going through a bit of pause, or just struggling with dreadle or thyroid issues.
So hopefully this will be helpful and this is going to be helpful for anyone,
whether they're a patient here or not. So try these herbs. First choice would be
adaptogenic herbs. Now, adaptogenic herbs were named several decades ago because the properties
of certain herbs have what are called adaptogenic qualities. That means they help you adapt
to your environment. If your thyroid is too high in that particular time, adaptogenic herbs
can bring it down. If it's too low, adaptogenic herbs can bring it up. Say with the adrenals,
say with the progesterone and estrogen, adaptogenic herbs really in my book should be the first thing
that a person goes to because it's hard to really hurt yourself with them. You could take
too much of anything, understand. Our approaches always start real low with any dosage. We'll talk
about that in a second. But many of the adaptogenic herbs don't cause any real blockages in any
metabolic pathways, except maybe Rodeola, which we'll talk about in a second. But they are,
they're really good choices because they can deal with even a person with a clinically low thyroid
and try to not take medication and get on a synthetic medication using adaptogenic herbs can
really help bring balance. Certainly, adaptogenic herbs should be the first thing you think of when
you're going through stressful situations. So during stressful situations, stressful event,
the death of the family, a change of jobs, movie, et cetera, going to adaptogens should be your
first choice. It can really help deal with the stress, help you deal with the different changes of
moods, et cetera. And here are some choices that I would start with. Aluthero, Alutheracoccus,
sentococcus is Siberian jinsing, which really technically isn't jinsing. It's in the jinsing
family, but not in the geos or species of the korean jinsing. But Aluthero is maybe the best
adaptogen. There's some argument in there, but Aluthero can work really well for people.
Ashwagad is another one that can work really well. Gaito Stibba is another great adaptogen.
Maybe has the strongest adaptogen quality, and you might have to start with a lower dosage of it.
But most adaptogen products that are out in the market will contain a combination, usually a
combination of panicked jinsing, ashwagad, aluthero, and rodeola, maybe some shasadra, some holy basil.
And usually those products can be very beneficial for people. We're going to talk about some
product choices in just a second. But those products would be very beneficial. The only thing
that I'd caution you about is using rodeola. If you know that you have some epigenetic defects,
and if that's a new word for you, maybe check our website and look at the genetic defects and
look at genetic profiles, videos that we have on the website, because that will help you understand
what I'm talking about. But we tend to use, we used to use products that were combination products,
so multiple different adaptogenic herbs in the product. But as we became a little more sophisticated
as a clinic and more specific, looking at different metabolic pathways, now we're steady to use
single products. So we're testing a person on aluthero and see if that works or testing a person
just an ashwagad, see if that works, and we'll use that product on them. Simply because some of
the mixture products can have some herbs that affect other pathways and cause issues. So if you try
to adapt a genetic combination product to the past and said, oh, this didn't work, don't give up
on adaptogens. Go to some single products and some more maybe some more trusted brands and try those
because I'll tell you, if you had to choose, if somebody asked me, is there one supplement
that you could only choose that you, you were going to move to Siberia, the only thing you could
bring with you is one supplement. I guess the supplement would be an adaptogen because that can help
you through the most obscure situations because they can even be helpful to help bring the immune
system back into balance. So adaptogens would really be probably my first choice. The second group
of herbs that you want to look at when you're talking about hormone issues is maybe not really an
herb at all. So I got to cheat it on this one. But whatever you're dealing with hormone issues,
you have to deal with getting rid of, quote, unquote, bad estrogens. Bad estrogens are produced by
plastics in our environment. They're produced by drugs that are in our water system. They're produced
by foods that were eating that animals that are ejected with hormones to grow quicker. The estrogens
are all around us. There's no way that you could move to a mountain top and get rid of them.
It's the, you could run, but you cannot hide, get it away from bad estrogens. It's just not a choice.
Everyone has to learn to deal with them. So some of the things that I think are really important
to take and we put a lot of people on a product called Diab, which is actually a product that's
synthesized from broccoli and cruciferous vegetables. And taking a product with Diab in it
can be super, super helpful. I mean, literally 100 to 500 milligram dosage of Diab, you'd have to
eat 20 pounds of broccoli to get the same amount of Diab that you'd get from broccoli. But Diab has
the ability to bite and get rid of bad estrogens in your body. This is super important. Not just
for while I'm trying to prevent breast cancer. So I don't want bad estrogens in my body. Well,
that's enough reason right there to take it. But it has to do with affects so many other things in
your life. And we're not just talking about women, it affects men, just as bad. So Diab and fermented
soy is another favorite of ours. Fermented soy, so I'm not a fan of soy products. So there's a
difference between soy and fermented soy. Fermented soy has the ability to dislodge bad estrogens
as they attach to apoptonic receptors in the cell membrane. So that's what causes cancer. So
when a bad estrogen attaches to an et al receptor, which is also considered an estrogen receptor
on a cell membrane, it blocks the process of normal program cell death apoptosis.
And that's what could lead to cancer. That's why bad estrogens could lead to cancer. So
Diab does not dislodge that bad estrogen from that receptor site. Diab grabs the bad estrogens
that are in your body and helps you get rid of them. Fermented soy has the ability to actually dislodge
and acts kind of like a crowbar, popping the bad estrogen out of the receptor site. So
that cell could go through apoptosis and die. So when a cell doesn't go through apoptosis and die,
it stays alive through its normal cell life cycle. It can go into rapid replication. And that's
what cancer is. So fermented soy could be very beneficial. Fermented soy could be
great for a person that already has cancer. So a person that already has cancer,
dimmed fermented soy are still good choices. A person that doesn't have cancer, still great choices.
But there's a difference between soy and fermented soy. But I had to include these because whatever
we're talking about, hormone issues, hormone issues can lead to worse things. So they're just
hot flashes or tiredness, chronic fatigue, et cetera, can lead to cancer. So I have to include
this piece, even though those are herbs. So I cheated on that a little bit. And three is estrogen
progesterone balancing herbs. So as number one was the adaptogens, which really can benefit
more so the thyroid and the adrenal gland and the pituitary, therefore indirectly affecting estrogen
progesterone. This category is specific to estrogen progesterone. These herbs affect the
thyroid and the adrenal, adrenal, much less, more so affecting estrogen and progesterone issues.
So macca, black cohoche, dunquai, epimedium, sumerute, wildium, and the rest on this list are very,
very beneficial with dealing with either low progesterone issues, unable to get pregnant,
low progesterone issues, dealing with pre-medstrual, cid robe issues, bloated, paid,
and people that are going through hot flashes and perimenopausal issues and postmenopausal issues.
These are great products. Now these you could take more so in a combination product usually.
We use a lot, and I'm going to plug this, the estrovite that we use, that's an apex product,
because it's been such a blessing to people. I mean people have, we've had women that literally have
said, if you get rid of that product, I will hunt you down and find out where I could get it because
it has been, it's literally just solved. You have hot flashes every day, and it's just,
to my understanding, it's very disturbing, so it can be very beneficial to have this product. We've
used macca directly as a single product and taken women that have not been able to get pregnant for
years and get pregnant, so it can be very helpful. So we use some of these single products,
depending on the person, and we use some combination products with this one.
So what kind of product do you choose? What's going to be the best for you as an individual?
What's going to be the best choice for you? I can't tell you that without you getting an exam,
but us knowing what's going to be what your issues are and us doing a workout on you.
Obviously, everybody watching this video, I can't help, but here's some rules to follow.
Is the product natural? So don't be fooled by the label. From a legal standpoint with supplements,
you could say it's a natural, all natural supplement. All that means is they didn't purposefully put
arsenic in it. They didn't add a poison to it. Therefore, it's all natural. Is it arsenic-free?
Not necessarily. So a product that could be, quote, unquote, all natural, could be as far from
natural as possible. It's just crazy the labeling rules that do not exist with supplementation.
People bring in supplements that are just literally garbage supplements that they paid a lot of
money for. And this is where supplements get a bad name. People will say, I tried Ashwagoda and it
didn't work. When you tried Kmart brand, Ashwagoda, and it was a joke. There was a study that was
done about a year ago when I published this on my blog that showed that an independent group
went into, I believe, Target Walgreens and, I don't know, GNC or something like that. They bought
Echinacea and several other herbs from those companies. Brought them back attested them and they
had like zero Echinacea in the product. They're just still labeling laws on this. So you can say,
you know, 100 milligrams of Echinacea, it has zero Echinacea in it. I just don't get it. I don't
wonder people don't get better with herbs. And don't wonder there's doctors who say herbs don't work.
It's because most herbs on the market don't work because they're not even what they say they are
clinically on the label. And this gets very discouraging for patients because they go,
well, how do I know what to believe? And who do I trust, et cetera? You have to use a trusted
source. So we have our trusted sources that we use, that companies that we've used successfully and
because we do testing on people, we know that they test to work on people. It don't get me wrong.
There's some really good products out there. Patients bring in a product. We always like to use
theirs because they already paid for them. And I'm not the business assembly products for good
to say. So it's, we'd rather use their product. So many times they test out perfect. Use that product.
Great. But it's hard to know. Is it a trusted source or not? Part of it is if you got it really cheap.
It's probably really cheap. So that's the issue. I don't want to pay that much for it.
Well, you kind of get what you pay for with a lot of supplements. And unfortunately,
you could have an expensive product that's just as bad too. Another thing is you got to be careful
of added stimulants because some, some, some supplement companies will literally put a
stimulant in their supplements so that people, quote, unquote, feel better when they take it.
Sad, isn't it? We'll just put some MSG in it. Hiding as a natural, uh,
flavorate or natural additive, quote, unquote, we could legally do that,
according to the FDA. And because it's MSG, it stimulates your brain,
neurotransmitters. And wow, I really feel good after taking that. I want more. It makes you crave
that supplement. And I got to keep taking the supplement because I really feel better afterward.
So just how you feel is it? How is the right choice? And then lastly, don't be fooled that,
oh, let's, the recommendation is to take one of these a day. So I'm going to take five a day
because that will really help me. More is not always better. And you do have to be careful.
These do affect your body. If they didn't affect your body, you would need to be taking them.
So more is not always better. Matter of fact, my say it is always too much of a good thing is a bad
thing. So even if it doesn't negatively affect your body, you take more of it. Your liver has to
detoxify it. That's not good to take up space in your liver to detoxify a supplement that you're
reporting to your body. So how we start with a low dosage on whatever you do. Try to get
organic sources, try to get ones that are independently tested. We use some different products that we
get an independent test lab report on every batch that we get. And it's from a certified organic
source. Those are the kind of products I like to use. They tend to test out the best. So just
something to remember and following those rules. Find a doctor that's local that you trust that
can test you out of the specific products. That's always probably the best rule of thumb.
When you take too many things, and this is the biggest mistake we see with anybody taking
supplements, when you take too many things, it can be an issue. So always be careful in what you're
doing. All right, hope this was beneficial. Sorry for the phone called noise if you heard that in
the back row. But always want to be a blessing to you and contact us if you have any questions. Thanks.